[Musique]
bonjour voilà lé voilà la bande annonce
mais il faut retourner le truc parce que
c'est long voilà la bande annonce
je vous offre un aperçu d'une créature
légendaire des temps anciens nice un
jeune homme gît cortège on lui a donné
moult non
en fait c'est suzanne
suzanne oui suzanne c'est un nom de
femme
oui c'est tout à fait ça c'est un joli
dont il faut quelqu'un qui connaisse les
endroits les plus sauvages de la planète
votre nom restera gravé comme celui du
plus grande aventure expliqué ce que
vous attendez actuellement deux manches
je me sens il n'ya personne de marasme
mais de l'autre côté du nombre peu
parlent de cette créature le yéti je
pense que ces critiques sont ni cousin
vous voulez bien me conduire je vous en
donne ma parole
d'accord c'est quoi quoi la bonne parole
aux c'est une façon de parler
ça sonne bien c'est quoi well as monaco
et nous reste beaucoup de route mais
nous avons deux journées une tarte
gravité vous allez craquer sur le mur
bravo merci comme nous projetons de
voyager à travers tout le globe
il va falloir pour la joue profil bas
mon dieu ça ça va laisser passer un
sacré courants d'air
[Musique]
voyons si j'ai bien tout compris tu as
l'intention de voyager tout au cours de
leurs terres jusqu'à l'a compris des
yétis je connais un chemin à travers les
montagnes boucher gamme ou pas p tit ne
parlait pas des poules est pas tous les
héros poulet salutations vénérable gamme
c'est un grand honneur
elle fait quoi et que le poulet ne vous
inquiétez pas de survie nous allons
trouver votre foyer
c'est la boîte
celui-là
sans gulou nous nous disons ceci
qu'est ce que cela veut dire partez
nouveau aïssou
à m'élancer voix vous êtes un peu lourd
à mon avis foutaise aller de toutes vos
forces
oh je sais pas qui c'est la faute sur ce
coup là et on recommence
[Musique]